for over two decades Tom Watson stood
shoulder-to-shoulder with successive
labor leaders with one public vow I
promise to back a new leader a hundred
percent I plan to do exactly that and I
ask you to do the same a feared backroom
fixer who took center stage as deputy
leader in 2015 with his own mandate
connections and worldview now after the
third high profile resignation of his
career this time quitting politics
altogether
he has unburdened himself for the first
time speaking to The Guardian newspaper
he said the point is that the brutality
and hostility is real and it's
day-to-day so I just thought now's the
time to take a leap do something
different you've had a good innings
you've done good stuff go now for some
Labour MPs who reforms and won their
seats concern over brutality rings true
the Labour Party's lost four elections
in less than a decade we went into this
election completely unprepared we didn't
have candidates we'd had all the
nastiness of D selection fights all the
rest of it we had no organization to
speak up we couldn't order vote labor
posters this was you know his pathetic
members deserved a lot better Tom Watson
could have walked away from the Labour
Party earlier this year taking dozens of
MPs with him do you think he regrets
that he didn't do that
it's Jeremy Corbyn and the people around
him who have broken the Labour Party
change UK formed because they refused to
listen because they refused to change
their their supporters intimidation and
tactics at local and national level that
is the reason the Labour Party broke tom
was trying to fix it from within and I
think that's a credit to him helping fix
it for Gordon Brown to take over from
Tony Blair in 2006 was just one of the
pivotal moments when Tom Watson helped
shape Labour's future he and his allies
might have thought he was fixing things
but those around Jeremy Corbyn did not
as he led a faction in shadow cabinet
calling for a second referendum sparking
apoplexy in the leaders office Tom
Watson you know he was part of creating
some of that brutality in the party is
the honest truth I've suddenly vote for
Tom Watson in 2015 and Eastern the
ticket of unity and to support the
leader the Labour Party and sadly during
his tenure that was something he not he
did not do
Tom Watson's excoriating assessment of
what went wrong in labor h key behind me
suggests he thinks the leadership got
the tactics wrong the tone the message
the policies even the advisors but he
doesn't directly criticize jeremy corbyn
that's Labour's problem if the party is
going to move on from the worst defeat
since the second world war could it
really afford to tiptoe around the
subject of leadership Tom Watson has
undergone a transformation losing seven
stone and training to be a fitness
instructor next year his legacy depends
on labour undergoing yet another of its
own transformations Sam Coates going to
use Westminster